There's some lovely representations of
of Paradise.
This is a garden of earthly delights.
What's his name?
Say That Bosh?
Yes.
Hieronymus Bosch.
He has a crazy.
I mean if you,
how he didn't get burnt at the stake is
absolutely beyond me.
I mean,
you know,
some of you know about Salvador Dali,
I suppose most of you do.
I mean delis a piker compared to
Hieronymus Bosch.
Man,
you could spend because there's three
pieces of this particular painting.
You could spend a very bizarre and
surreal month looking at that painting.
I don't know what it was with Bosch,
but he was some sort of creature that
only popped up once and probably for the
best.
And so there's been very many
representations of Paradise Mean God
only knows what that is.
It's like I could probably guess,
but I won't.
And then look,
I mean that's,
that's,
that's the lion lying down with the
lamb.
Right?
So that's this idea that's maybe
projected back in time that there was a
time or maybe will be a time when,
when the,
the horrors of life are no longer
necessary for life itself to exist.
Right.
And the horrors of life,
or of course that everything eats
everything else and that everything dies
and that everything is born in the whole
bloody places at charnel house and it's,
it's a catastrophe from beginning to
end.
And this is,
this is the vision of it being.
Other than that.
And you know,
there's a strong idea.
This was also in implicit in the
alchemical ideas and I think it's also
implicit in the scientific revolution
that human beings can interact with
reality in such a way so that the tragic
and evil elements of it can be
mitigated.
And so that we can move somewhat closer
to a state that might be characterized.
Well,
that's obviously imagistic,
but it might be characterized by
something like that where we have the
benefits of actual existence without all
of the catastrophe.
That seems to go along with it.